Today, the question is, are we ready to routinely treat smoldering multiple myeloma?
Very hot debate.
These are my disclosures.
Remember, when we're talking about smoldering myeloma, the current definition of smoldering
myeloma is between 10% and 60% plasma cells since the Slim Crab revision, or an M-spike
of 3 grams per deciliter, or 24-hour Bench Jones protein of 500 milligrams, and absolutely
no myeloma-defining symptoms.
And in terms of distinguishing between MGUS and smoldering myeloma, we should remember
that smoldering myeloma is more common than we think.
In the I-STOP-MM study, half a percent of the people over 40 in Iceland were found to
have smoldering myeloma on this screening project.
And using this online tool, when you have a patient, an asymptomatic patient with a monoclonal
protein.
It tells us about 40% of patients need a bone marrow biopsy.
And if you follow that rule, if you follow the recommendations from this tool, about
a third of the patients you biopsy will end up having smoldering myeloma.
So it's important to think about this and not just assume everybody has MGUS.
And we know that not all smoldering myeloma is the same.
The risk is not 10% across the board.
There are some patients.
This is the current IMWG risk strategy.
The 22-20 plus high-risk cytogenetics.
And if you use those risk factors as continuous parameters, there's a subgroup that has as
high as a 72% risk at two years of progressing to symptomatic multiple myeloma.
There's also biological rationale for treating smoldering multiple myeloma, less acquired
resistance, less clonal heterogeneity.
And then there's this.
There's patient-driven reasons, right?
So patients who pursue therapy for smoldering myeloma are a pretty self-selected group of
patients.
Once you start talking about the data that we're going to review today, some of them
really want to be on therapy.
They can't accept the idea of doing nothing, even if their risk is not 72% at two years.
Some of them feel the need to do something, and that drives decision-making for all of
us.
We're also entering, I would say, a
degeneration.
We're also entering, I would say, a degeneration.
A different era in terms of assessing risk, and this is coming pretty fast, right?
So molecular profiling, looking for other drivers.
This is work that was mostly done at Miami, but it was a national collaboration.
They identified 20-something molecular factors, identifiable molecular factors, which drive
risk.
And then there were four of them, and maybe not surprising ones, the presence of RAS
mutations, APOBEC.
profile MYC abnormalities also drive risk. And they use this model to sort of functionally
divide patients with asymptomatic plasma cell diseases into genomic myeloma and genomic MGUS.
And you can see here that even patients who were diagnosed with MGUS, some of them already have
the genomic profile that looks more like myeloma. So these patients may functionally be like
smoldering myeloma patients. So we don't need to spend a ton of time going over the few randomized
trials looking at smoldering myeloma. The first one was the QUERIDEX Spanish trial,
a somewhat problematic randomized trial based on when treatment was initiated in each arm,
how smoldering myeloma was defined. But at a 12-year follow-up publication,
the difference in time to progression was seven years.
The second one was a trial that was done in two arms. And the difference in time was seven years.
And the second one was a trial that was done in two arms. And the difference in time was seven years.
And the second one was a trial that was done in two arms. And even though early survival was
problematic and very concerning that the observation group had a survival more like myeloma,
not like smoldering myeloma, ultimately, overall survival ended up being long for both groups,
but different. And patients responded well to next line of therapy when they progressed,
regardless of which arm they were on. We also have the, you know, the, you know, the, you know,
the ECOG study, which defined high-risk smoldering somewhat differently. More along the lines of how
we think about it now, although not including cytogenetic risk as part of it. This was lenalidomide
alone versus observation. And this was len to progression. And not surprisingly, the len group
had longer time to progression. PFS was quite different. I think the thing, the important
thing to remember about this, and I think the thing we learned, this was,
the len until progression, but only two-thirds of patients were still on therapy at one year.
And of those two-thirds, 80% of them had had dose reductions already. And the delivered dose
intensity was 55% in that two-thirds who were still on treatment. So this really ended up being
finite therapy. And also the PFS difference was completely driven by the high-risk
smoldering myeloma group in this subset.
And sort of established that only high-risk smoldering myeloma really ought to be treated,
not even intermediate risk. We have the AQUILA trial, which I think for patients changed thinking
quite a bit. In my practice, I think I have more patients who've been interested in daratumumab
therapy than lenalidomide therapy. This was a randomization between DARA given in standard
fashion, sub-Q, versus observation. And we can see here that five-year progression-free survival,
strong progression-free survival. And we have a lot of patients who have been interested in
daratumumab therapy. And we have a lot of patients who have been interested in daratumumab therapy.
And there was also a small difference in overall survival as well. And in the patients who
progressed, the observation patients were more likely to have true CRAB progressions rather than
slim CRAB biochemical progressions than in the DARA arm. So the current NCCN guidelines
recommend not treating lower intermediate risk at all. They recommend for high-risk patients,
clinical trials, and high-risk patients. And they recommend for high-risk patients,
clinical trials, when they're available, and somewhat favor DARA over lenalidomide. But those
are the two options that are being presented, that are basically being considered. And so
we have to think about, so what are we trying to accomplish with therapy? And so there's kind of
different philosophies, delay versus cure. And delay is you're trying to avoid overtreatment.
You're reluctant to treat patients and expose patients to risk who don't actually,
aren't going to progress. And so we're minimizing toxicity,
and we're trying to avoid treatment-related deaths. Whereas the cure approach,
we're trying to eradicate disease, trying to tackle that pre-resistant
state. And there have been several studies looking at very intensive myeloma-like approaches
to treating smoldering. And these, unlike the trials I just showed you, are actually
making patients MRD negative at least half the time. And so,
potentially, I think has the, at least the potential to be eradicating disease. So here
are my conclusions. We know there are some patients who should be treated. Our job right now
is to give patients the data so that they can make decisions. And again, in my own practice,
that seems to be daratumumab more often than lenalidomide. Clinical trials remain a top
preference. And I'm just going to tee up the topic of the bispecifics, the BCMA-targeted therapies,
you know, I showed you that scale, and it's always a choice between mild therapy that never
puts patients into an MRD state versus super-intensive therapy, which does. And you're
trying to decide which route do you want to go. We're about to enter an era where you don't have
to make that choice. We now have very tolerable therapies that are making patients MRD negative
quite quickly. And so, BCMA-targeted therapies are a great example of an approach that may
be the optimal approach for smoldering myeloma. And as we do this, in addition to studies
which explore new therapies, we should remember that our definition of risk continues to evolve
and we're entering a molecular era where we're going to be defining patients in that way
as well. And that's what I got. Thank you.